hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will learn how to build and how
to use slicers in Excel that said if
these are the type of videos you'd like
to watch then hit that like And
subscribe buttons and the bell icon to
get notified just for your quick info if
you want to upskill yourself master data
science and data analytics skills and
learn your dream job or growing your
career the new must explore simply learn
SC of various data science and analytics
programs simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like
Caltech C IIT conour and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready experience in
skills like Advanced Excel python
machine learning data visualization
generative Ai and over a dozen others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
on Top Tire data and product companies
and academics from top universities I
after completing these courses thousands
of Learners have transitioned into a
data science or moved on to a higher
paying job and profile if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and in the
description box below to find a data
science and data analytics program that
fits your experience and areas of
Interest now without further delay let's
get started with our onepoint agenda
that is slicers in Excel now let's get
back to the Practical mode where we have
a spread sheet so this is our
spreadsheet and this particular table
has employee ID employee name
designation Department salaries employee
date of birth and employee date of
joining Now by default this might not be
a data table but you can convert it into
a table just select all and press
control T and this particular shortcut
will convert your data table into an
actual table on Microsoft Excel now the
process is simple select all your data
go go to insert option and here hope
that you can find slices and timelines
go with slicers and now select the
slicer that you want to be included into
your data spreadsheet now I would like
to include employee ID employee name
designation department now press okay
and you will have all the slices you
need just organize them in the way you
want let's say I want to organize all of
them on the right side of my data table
there you go and this one over here and
and this one over here now let's say I
wanted to find a particular set of
values from the
designation
contract and uh Department as analytics
and I have the data of those particular
employees who are on contract basis
hired by analytics department so these
are like filters you can just make your
filters happen just by one click on your
slice options now let's say I want also
the manager contract so here I can do
that by selecting this particular option
over here if I don't select this option
it will only give me one by default but
if I want multiple selections you can
just click on that and give multiple
options and then you have the data you
require so that's how you build and use
slices in Excel and with that we have
come to an end of the session on how to
build and how to use slices in Excel if
you have any queries regarding any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you require the resources that we used
in this session please let us know in
the comment section below and our team
of experts we'll be happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply Lear